aux etats unis le verdict dans le
jugement de kyle rittenhouse n'en finit
plus d'agiter le débat politique pour la
justice le jeune homme de 18 ans a agi
en légitime défense lorsqu'il a tué deux
personnes dans le wisconsin en 2020 en
marge des manifestations anti raciste
une affaire qui symbolisent les
divisions de la société américaine sur
les questions communautaires la
correspondance de thomas bonnet à
washington
depuis son acquittement kyle gitana
aussi devenu un outil de débat politique
ici aux etats-unis dernière preuve en
date la proposition par marjorie taylor
green élue républicaine à la chambre des
représentants d'accorder la médaille
d'or du congrès au jeune homme
fraîchement a quitté al estime qu'il
doit être reconnu comme un héros ayant
défendu sa communauté l'initiative a peu
de chances d'aboutir puisque elle doit
être validée par une majorité large de
parlementaires mais elle témoigne de
l'aspect très politique de cette affaire
d'ailleurs à dés la semaine dernière
lorsque le verdict a été annoncé il ya
eu de vives réactions jusqu'au plus haut
sommet de l'état tout en appelant à
respecter la décision des jurés à joe
biden a fait part de sa colère
scepticisme aussi du côté de la
vice-présidente kamala harris
le verdict parle vraiment de lui même
comme beaucoup le savent j'ai passé la
majorité de ma carrière a travaillé pour
rendre le système judiciaire plus
équitable et clairement il y a encore du
travail
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle joe biden avait publié
une vidéo établissant un lien entre le
cas de kyle rittenhouse et le
suprématisme blanc alors que cela n'a
jamais été démontrée cette affaire a
également relancé le débat sur le port
d'armes le second d'amendements et puis
sur la notion de légitime défense aux
états unis ce verdict a en tout cas été
accueillie comme une victoire par bon
nombre d'élus républicains et c'est donc
tout naturellement que l'ancien
président donald trump a invité kyle
rittenhouse chez lui dans sa résidence
de mara lago en floride l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche a
expliqué que le jeune homme était fan de
lui et c'est la raison pour laquelle il
avait décidé de l'inviter avec sa mère
dans sa résidence du sud des états unis
la photo de cette rencontre a été très
largement relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est une nouvelle illustration de la
portée politique qu incarne peut-être
malgré lui ce jeune américain de 18 ans